foreign
welcome welcome
hey Albert hey thoughts on fire hey Adam
hey caterial
how you guys doing
I do re meme
my Kalua fanboy
welcome welcome
kadzar
hello blind mic
hey brood
I'll start playing in a second hey gpg
I'm still getting the hang of uh
balancing playing and
interacting with you guys at the same
time so
give me a break
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory
evening Gregor hi Adam Hi basilisk
hey Max
hi Isaiah
thank you thank you
okay let's get into it
so I've just uh reached the goblin Camp
so it's just going to be
battle time in a second
let's see how this goes if you guys
enjoy the uh
streams please give it a like so that I
know
I will regret not joining us
because everyone here played the game
already
potato
ouch
thank you Max
I'm not even close to being in the game
how many goblins are there
I'm level 10 on this character
damn that guy's tough
uh no I haven't beaten the game
this is my second character but I
haven't beaten it
I've just been playing this one on
stream
I think basilisk
Rebellion
somebody there
is a number 12 so long of everything
I actually picked Slytherin for both
couldn't help myself
but uh I'll probably do a playthrough
with every house
no rush
yourself
[Applause]
which house did you guys pick
I know I haven't played a Harry Potter
game in a long time
I didn't throw that
you don't believe you can defeat me do
you
thank you ugly hair monster
appreciate that
folklore has some good stuff
okay yeah
thank you thank you I appreciate that
yeah I'll probably do like Hufflepuff
next Maybe
I might just delete my other character
and just continue so they're in with
this one
after a bit of dying are we
if only Ren Rock we're here to see this
foreign
trial
I don't know why I did both of them the
same house that wasn't a smart decision
foreign
that was quite something
now to free arms carts if you're
referring to the cursed Child movie
announcement then that is not true
that's still just a rumor I think
and this seems to happen every couple of
months
Rebellion
quite an enchantment
the cards returning to Arms
yeah I know it's uh it keeps happening
happens all the time
how do you do this trial of Merlin here
does anyone know I should go back and do
it
I'm assuming I have to stay with the
cards
ah three sets of five balls okay
have a good night
I have the Mellow Suite I think I need
wingardium leviosity
ah yeah
didn't think of that
thank you
okay that's one
that's one
Rebellion
there they are
there we go
and one more I guess revelio
uh
where is it
feels amazing
where's the third set of balls
should be one more right
huh
let me see if I can find this
head out of the main entrance of the
camp and turn right
it says
yeah I'll try outside
is this the main entrance
here
I ran past it
okay
oh is this it
revelio
where are the walls though
foreign
there we go
there we go a bit of a glitch
can everyone hear me okay
is that it that was anticlimactic
yeah that last set of stones was tricky
I'd like to Sweet see uh quidditch DLC
that would be cool
thank you sir
no worries
foreign
hey Roberto hey clinics
hey Kalua
incendio Rebellion
lightsabers here multiplayer would be
cool but I don't I think we may get that
eventually but
yeah try was a tournament that's
definitely feasible I think
Quidditch
Diagon Alley
yeah I feel the same way
the tree that came done too soon
I'm playing on PS5 yeah
if you guys enjoy this stream please
give it a like
hey that's a problem with introducing
these this DLC is it then it's less
consistent with Canon
potentially
yeah I think the multiplayer approach
type is for eight players maximum
um
but it's still in early days
and it's not made by Porky
is it bad on PC
on I have good news your cards are on
their way back I don't know what to say
any hope I have of getting my belongings
back was quickly fading ramrock's a lot
called me a fool for believing in the
good and wizard kind
thank you for proving them wrong
I managed to free your carts fairly
easily I'm glad you're all right oh I
can't wait to have my things back
especially my paints ah
you know you've inspired me
I've been dealing with perhaps my next
Piece Will
do you mean uh sectum sempra
what's a nice idea on I wish you luck
with it oh I can't wait to get
Rebellion
all the best to you
[Music]
I've done a video on the difference
between charms curses spells hexes
jinxes
foreign
I'd be happy to show you my Wares not
sure how I'd fare in a little place like
this
foreign
if I want to do quests with him
do I have to find him or do I just
complete the main quests
thank you thank you I'm donut
Okay so
okay gotcha is that at a certain level
that I get a owl mail from him
gotcha okay well maybe I'll do the
the main quest
gotcha gotcha gotcha
oh level 11.
that would be cool I haven't really been
recording everything
maybe I could do that with with one
playthrough
foreign
no
Snape is much more powerful than Harry
much more powerful
yeah but I think that Snape is
inherently much more powerful than Harry
as well
I think my favorite creature is uh maybe
a Demento
but I think I don't think they're
classified as
they beasts I can't remember
they're not beings they're non they're
non-beings
there's a whole classification system
but the ministry
foreign
yeah I wish Snape stayed alive yeah
thestral was a good choice too
what's everyone's favorite creature
comment
this looks intriguing
is this a trial of Merlin
how do you get into this cave
Akio the cube okay
cool cool
is this a bad idea
oh my
yeah I was expecting a lot more by this
cave
bit disappointing
what's everyone's uh favorite spell
hey Darcy
yeah and very would be
well positioned there
instantly
bombarded yeah it's a good choice lots
of good choices
Mr midnight what did you make your uh
one Dev
[Music]
scrope who is scrope
yeah unsupported flight that's called
I put out a video today on 20 spells
that were created by different powerful
witches and wizards
I might do a giveaway of the game
I love the game
where's this uh this note then
that's it
back here oops
[Music]
pumpkins
ah I think I know just the place
I'm gonna make a video on
um Molly killing Bellatrix and my take
on the ancient magic side of things
uh that'll probably come out this week
huh
thank you thank you
what else do I have coming out
I have a video on the
um history of Avada cadaver coming out
and then I've got one on Ancient magic
and Molly Weasley
I would you know I haven't beaten the
game but so far I would say you know
it's Canon I'd like to consider it to be
Canon
Rebellion
where is this scroll
back here
[Music]
down to the water's edge
this better not be a trick
thanks mescon
uh no I don't read fan fictions
not really occasionally
I'll write them occasionally as well
Harry Potter is real yeah
I don't play a lot of games but my
favorite game of all time is Kotor
apologies of notes because wanted to be
sure you weren't followed what's this
all about
you'll notes mentioned the book I found
in the Restricted Section scrap can tell
you more in exchange for your help you
here is playing
now
the rumors of um
Harry Potter coming back
are fake
undermining the Headmaster and getting
something in return
continue how scrub does not intend to
undermine the Headmaster in fact stroke
wants to surprise him
scrapes like mistress Apollonia black
may she rest in peace it was a student a
Hogwarts her over 50 years ago before
she died she spoke with passion of pages
ripped from a book scrub suspects she
took them to her private Grotto
so she was delirious no they're just uh
this happens every couple of months I'm
sorry to hear that some big media Outlet
will take a picture of Harry Ron and
Hermione and say cursed Child movie
is also in The Grotto scrap wishes to
give it to them
this game the fandom will potentially
spot Warner Brothers to take some action
maybe make a show or another film but
but when scrope there's nothing planned
yeah there's Pages scrub thought thought
you might also I'd like them to do a
movie on or a show on Tom Riddle's
Origins
Snape's Origins Marauders
um Hogwarts founders Dumbledore's
Origins
it's both a martial dirt scrope I've got
a video on it which is using guns
to The Grotto just down the coast
and place it on the pedestal there good
luck
scope will wait right here for you it's
still luck finding your pages to end the
ring
what was it you needed me to do scrope
scrub wooden
it seems this may help us both a martial
dirt scrope is really hi Matt scrope
hoped the young Slytherin would be
willing to help if you guys could pick a
prequel who made what would you choose
place it on the pedestal there good luck
hi Sarah
sorry Soraya
yourself
oh no
in San Francisco
this is bad this is bad this is bad
why are there so many of these things
they have a lot of Health hey
instantly
always
foreign
not doing very well
it's
for the honest
incending
almost
damn
Leviosa and Defender okay
good to know
those things aren't easy to kill I think
that's the hardest thing I've had to
fight
yeah that was tough
revelio
foreign
why would I need a piece of toast
propose that's where it goes
it's the giant squid
foreign
I was a student just like you about a
century ago how in the world did you
find this place a household named scrope
sent me said I might find a black family
ring ah sorry to say I sold the ring I
can't say I blame him I stole I thought
a secret map I pilfered from peeves with
what would I want with yellowed old
Pages torn from a book
I must insist that you give them to me
at once they're not here I thought if
Apollonia wasn't interested in the map
on the page you guys enjoy the screen
so I followed them here's an idea
why don't you meet me at the edge of the
I suppose if that's the only way for me
to get those pages I'll meet you at the
forest I'm sure the pages are still
tucked in my waistcoat if you don't mind
the sight of a
revelio
so lumos the posts on the bridge
it doesn't appear to be connected to the
missing pages
hang on to it for now
I think Dumbledore and Gandalf we get
along here
hey link how's it going welcome back
I think uh I don't know we don't know
enough about Merlin but apparently he
was
essentially the most powerful wizard
ever so
I've got to give it to him
then Dumbledore second
also Morgana lafaye
who was uh Merlin's nemesis
very powerful
she was the first animagus
hello enjoy dinner for you I was able to
enter apollonia's Grotto the toast was
the key I met a ghost there Richard
jackdaw who's agreed to lead me to the
pages I've been looking for that boy was
never good enough for Apollonia
oh what of the black family ring I'm
sorry to say that jackdaw sold it long
ago thank you thank you indeed
scrubs you'll need to think of another
way to impress the Headmaster
scope takes some consolation in knowing
that the young Slytherin found what they
needed I did if you guys have questions
about the game you're incredible
questions about the law that you want
covered then go to my latest video which
I published today and leave a comment
as I look through all the comments
[Music]
I don't think so Soren
I think Dumbledore beats a million lines
foreign
I think a Hufflepuff is
by far the most underappreciated
I don't think it's even close
so they're in Gryffindor get all the
love probably Slytherin the most then
Gryffindor then Ravenclaw then
um Hufflepuff
my least favorite founder
is probably Hufflepuff just because of
her
magical ability
um
oh I'm going the wrong way
foreign
um I think
I think Hermione wins after Voldemort's
soul is stripped from Harry
off on another adventure are we
foreign
[Music]
was this a spider's Den
hey Kelvin
back here
foreign
damn
just keep coming
huh
here's the quest
okay good to know
here I am as good as my world
foreign
okay so I think I have to do what is
that lumos on some candles
to find it
lumos
this is the bridge isn't it
Rebellion
oh I shall enjoy this oh is it the
entrance
how do you know that
okay
one of these ones
lumos
Enchanted candles uh-huh wonder where
they're heading
very nice
the candles seem to be leading into the
Forbidden Forest
foreign
Poppins would be a powerful path for a
Gryffindor
extreme Danger
the treasure must be nearby
treasure hunting suits me
you deselect the um map tracking for the
purple
never mind
what house would Magic Mike be in
I don't know
thank you
I think that baji Crouch Jr was a
a good defense against the dark arts
teacher regardless even though he was a
Death Eater an active Death Eater I
think he did a good job
he was a bit harsh Maybe
no I'm not a Star Wars Theory
but he is a partner on this channel
uh yeah I have the deluxe version
I did a promotion with Warner Brothers
and they gave me a copy
foreign
yeah I know that I'm not even bothering
with my character's appearance
not yet
yeah I know
foreign
what do I have Phoenix Feather core
12 inches made a view
here I am as good as my word we meet
again Richard jackdaw
I suppose I shouldn't be surprised to
see you it took the cunning of a
Slytherin to track down these Pages well
said now where do we go from here follow
me I shall lead you as well I can I
appreciate that fear I may remain
important to revisit the scene of My
Demise keep your eyes open for a bud as
you can imagine I never paid much
attention in school
shall we
aside from the bird bath anything else I
should look for
a few lands
if I recall a lake you'll see
you've been very helpful
thank you thank you Ari
uh I'll I like cheese
cheese is good what does everyone think
of cheese surprising how much of this is
rather unfortunately coming back to me
you know the closer we get the more I'm
remembering
probably best I leave you to it simply
stick to the past and keep a sharp eye
out for that bird bath
had you
is that Latin this area is considered
Dangerous by the ministry of magic
excellent
nothing to do now but keep going
seems safe
like a safe place
the waterfall
for a thief Jackal surprisingly as good
as his word
bin Forest is safe what are you talking
about
oh
Rebellion
what do we have here
protagon
incendio
Rebellion
I think that Harry was
definitely carried by
Voldemort's soul to a certain extent
uh oh
how do you open the buff scheme then
something oddly solemn about this place
such Regal creatures stacks
there it is
all described
intramuros
revelio
aren't you a little far from us
knew you'd eventually lead us to
whatever it is you're hiding
why can't I hit
I risk those loyalists will report back
to randwick now
see where Jack door has led me
if you guys enjoy the stream please give
it a like
What the how big this place is
yeah I know I always try and use it too
far away
I'm capable of learning
oops
need to light all three incentives
okay let's see what what's about someone
didn't want casual visitors down there
do this
wasn't so bad not yet
oh
I'm not gonna Touch first whoa
said
instead
uh yeah I keep my live streams up I do
you should be able to find the last uh
four that I did
L1 and R1 at the same time okay I didn't
even know that
foreign
yeah I'll show you the ones how do I
show it
here it is
thank you
damn
I don't think I've used my ancient magic
yet is it l1r1
just two of them
ah three
that's probably right Ari
incentive
foreign
cool
I like that
let me also
experience
easy
I like the look of this
not a headless skeleton in sight
but I may as well help myself to this
is cool I like this
I like this Quest
back here
there it is the bridge it's almost
complete
more spiders
thank you
ouch
I should have used the ancient magic I
keep forgetting I'll use Ancient Magic
on this one
love yourself
nice
badly
damn
that was intense
foreign
we meet again Richard Jack duel
thank you for keeping these Pages safe
all these years here it is the map the
port you're doing jackdaw
there's something Beyond this room
I don't like the look of this
love yourself
oh
who's this guy
whoa no way
ouch
I don't know what I was thinking that
Sunday
ouch
thank you
nice
damn those uh normal spells did nothing
for those guys
foreign
where am I
oh no the room's starting to flood
you bet Gustav
the plan is to stream kind of every
couple of days
until I've beaten the game
but I'm just gonna take my time
I'm not interested in blasting through
and not enjoying it
I can only hope this magic protects me
until I'm able to make my way out of it
what is this place
and I expect here guys
foreign
thank you thank you
can it be
it's here someone finally found our map
chamber I recognize you from the
pensives you'll Professor Rackham I am
indeed I must confess that I am
surprised to see someone so young
standing before me I'm the same age that
you and Isadora Morgan Arc were when you
started the Hogwarts you've paid
attention and might I presume you share
our ability
to see traces of ancient magic hey Ethan
yes sir I do
as you have likely realized by now our
ability gives us a unique relationship
with all forms of magic we can access
expressions of magic that few others can
opportunities will arise that allow you
to sharpen this rare Talent do not
squander them I won't Professor thank
you we have much to discuss but first
i'm going to do a video
here place the book on the pedestal I
don't have the book with me sir hmm that
is unfortunate I'm afraid we must pause
our conversation until you return with
the book
the statues and carvings and I am did
you know that I would be here I
very well I'll Retreat good we
which uh talent tree did you guys pursue
should I get this
oh interesting okay let me see
foreign
o
so to get confringo Mastery I have to
get levioso Mastery correct
foreign
I see oh so you have to learn the spell
and then you can okay apply Talent
points to it
should I get uh stupefy
foreign
I'll get stupefy
incendio is that
it's in uh spells
should I save the rest of them for now
or should I use all of them
is this any good the blood curse
foreign
spell sets are a must okay
so this one
both of these
I need to get spell knowledge 1 and 2.
okay maybe I don't need that yet
okay I'll save them
I don't need them right now
I found the pages and the map chamber
Department of the book
oh revelio with a bigger range how do I
do that one
which section is ravelio in
cool
okay not yet
not yet
okay so basic spellcast evasion and the
healing okay
let's do that
this one
okay I'll get it
noise
I'm I'm back at Hogwarts
I wonder when Professor fig will be back
I did promise him I wouldn't neglect my
studies while he was away suppose I have
enough to distract myself with till he
returns with a book
foreign
[Music]
level 12.
okay guys I think I'm done done for now
but I will be back tomorrow or
potentially the next day the banishing
charm useful for pushing objects or
adversaries away complete the required
tasks and meet me we should have Langley
everyone type Richard of Langley in the
chat
thank you thank you
okay all right see you guys
Robert of Loxley